welcome to this video playing John
determinator yes some of those kind of
them this macho names they are really
really popular right nobody is called
like mr. Rogan okay what to do here I
can I do something else I could play the
king's indian classical mainline our
case going nite a 60 and we don't get
bad okay Jeff probably five now then we
have a main main position of this night
a six Kings Indian which is some quite
popular in recent years this Bishop see
one I really can remember yeah it's been
ages then since I looked at this
yeah one key idea here is to play c5
that much I know Jen okay let's let's
kick black away here c5 now it's
probably just taking d4 I don't see the
point at the moment and maybe still
Bishop a6 somehow
now i don't know let's just develop him
i really don't know the opening a
mainline classically with Bishop b2 is
not so so much part of my repertoire
mostly play those early age three lines
or not the classical at all okay how to
play here maybe I can take place you
five okay let's let's speed up here I'm
really slow again
f5 might be a problem here now the
nygean f7 is having a pretty good
position for pushing at five that I
underestimated she can maybe even play a
five right away that's not so good my
idea was rootabahn c5 and so on but he
gets this Enya and he plays it oh not
good
f-for bishop a six maybe official a six
every three Bishop c4 yeah it wasn't it
wasn't really a successful opening f4 is
really possibly very annoying but
nothing that I can do much about yeah
not what I wanted to do definitely okay
yeah that's a this opening is really a
successful black okay i will play Bishop
c4 if he lets me but I doubt that he
does maybe there's also just g5 h5 well
then I maybe have to play Knight H to
try to prepare against the Jeep won't
push is taking lots of time why ok so
it's moving out of out of this you have
to have to put have to play look you one
somehow
94 and 94 you can play 94 take stakes
and then f 3 which is terrible for me
wow oh wow what a bad game this is this
is now this is a this is lost for white
this is not even bad this is a losing
position oh wow
amazing really amazing how how bad i can
play sometimes 92 and then f3 and I'm
toast em totally what yeah and it's very
easy to see 95 is also great but a free
ofn I mean f3 would have just killed me
this probably also but ok let's take it
at hope for the best f3 was just winning
for black here there are also many
dangerous possibilities I guess starting
with stuff like d3 maybe now it's not
winning I think and three would have
killed me here i'm not some not yet
seeing it but i said i suspect that
there's something here as well ok can
take here now this should take see head
and of course I mean the exchange is not
an issue I mean he will not take the
exchange yeah i think but do something
else but he's given up two pawns so i
mean there must be some sort of point
now otherwise i just play ok yeah
bishops III now acer is really fantastic
on or what exactly
check yeah let's let's start with that
and now I need to see where to put my
PCM night possibly Here I am 10 to f3 f3
g5 would be nice it's running right into
an IG time learning just not sure how
dangerous it is but I can go here I was
just also quite nice try to put it on
1g5 yeah with f3 he was just killing me
this was a terribly badly played game I
mean wow he might sacrifice the exchange
yes let's let's cover that i can if i
get an H for and 95 I don't want to lose
a couple of Tempe
check Brooke to g3 is coming ok it's not
that clear even here this weird weird
position like 430 on high yeah strange I
mean I was thinking it should be should
be easier I mean why this much better of
course but it's nothing like a total
like a chick made or anything yeah let
us look at when I was losing here I'm
losing and this is with f3 f3 is just
killing me completely if I take 95 and
this this this can just resign so I
cannot take the pawn I have to play
almost like that and then I mean yes
everything's good yeah 95 is great and
an IG five or I mean it this is terrible
i'm just i'm just lost here just lost
yeah and it wasn't great here anyway i
had I hadn't really appreciated enough
that this f5 move is hitting me so I
have to have to to be very modest here
probably with worth I mean this means
that the trade was was already bad yeah
I have to sort of prepare for a five in
some way I'm not quite sure how but not
not how I played that was very lucky
okay thanks for watching